okay so here we are my best friend adam
is challenging me to make this jiggly
cheesecake today that has been
popularized in japan
here's the jiggles they start with
lining the pan with raisins
and there's the cheesecake and then
there's like a very smooth rounded top
which then i'm gonna brand because
that's what they do in japan so i'm
gonna brand this cheesecake as my own
today
by the end of the day me and this
cheesecake should be looking like this
rie is here a very talented chef she's
gonna help
when i get stuck so the first thing i
need to do is i need to line my baking
pan
that's how we're going to pop it right
out um i need to cut this into a circle
so let me see how i can do that
like a butt harder than it looks
[Applause]
square
find the middle spot whoa for real
that's it yeah
thank you yes this is the tricky part i
need 130 milliliters of milk
i can't weigh milk right grandma miller
it's the same
really mm-hmm oh no it's too much
it's like gross this is on medium heat
100 grams of butter with the same amount
of cream cheese crumbs
in the milk until it's all kind of like
melted down into this nice creamy
mixture
i should have cut up the butter and the
cream cheese so while that's happening
i'm gonna crack some eggs
13 egg whites and four egg yolks
these are gonna mix drizzle this into
the egg yolks
i'm gonna put flour and cornstarch into
my
cream cheese and egg yolk mixture no
lumps no lumps
no lumps this is kind of lumpy and i
don't think it's supposed to be lumpy
why is it lumpy i slipped in the flour
okay so now a [ __ ] ton of egg whites
oh [ __ ]
i'm gonna use a spoon and pick it out
because my yolk broke
come on come on
you know what i think that's the best
i'm gonna do
okay 13 we did it oh my god gross i am
ready to
whisk my egg whites but i will have to
gradually add
sugar so i'm gonna add some cream of
tartar in
tartar tartar is it like tartar sauce
it's not the same anyways i'm putting
some cream of tartar into
this that's so stupid i don't know how
much of this to use
cream of tartar it can help make stiffer
peaks
i might just see what people normally
put in meringues
two recipes say a quarter of a teaspoon
so let's go quarter of a teaspoon looks
pretty stiff to me
i think i'm going to call it because i
don't want to over mix now i have to
slowly
fold in the egg whites into this big old
bowl
in the video they just like get a big
scoop and it pours in
pretty well but the texture looks really
different from mine
also i gotta put raisins on the bottom
here we go i feel kind of okay about
this
so this goes in here putting this in the
oven i'm gonna pour the water into the
water bath
i think it's gonna be heavy
look at this i did it okay now i gotta
pop it out this is the challenge ready
oh no that's gonna be that's how it
[Music]
cracks
[Music]
it jiggles oh my god it jiggles
yeah it tastes like hot hot eggs does
not taste like trees
wet on the bottom but look at a jiggle
oh it's just
egg it needs to
taste more like cheesecake okay attempt
number two
so definitely the consistency of the
first one did pretty well what i am
gonna change is the taste i'm gonna
add more cream cheese this time a couple
more egg yolks vanilla because usually
that makes baked goods tasty
and more sugar
oops
[Music]
why does this feel like more does this
look like more
it's got a big old crack in it but
hopefully it tastes more like cheesecake
and it's still jiggly
it looks very jiggly this is not gonna
work
oh
it broke i don't know if it's cooked
look at that it's still wet
tastes more like cheesecake so the taste
is there much better
there's a really big crack in it
we're back day two cheesecake number
three
i'm really scared that it only gets
worse from here we've made some
adjustments
hopefully it will taste more like
cheesecake and no cracks on top
um oh it's so cracked
i think this is the best taste so far
this is
crack we should bake different
temperature yeah lower temperature
what's up
you wanna try my cheesecake are there
raisins in this yeah
why we don't like raisins cheesecake
number four i'm determined that this
will be the last
we are adjusting some measurements less
batter overall we are also lowering the
temperature in the oven so that
hopefully the crack won't be so
significant the taste i think we had it
it wasn't browning so we turned the
temperature back up and literally within
like
one minute it just started burning
yeah it's a failure
oh my god what's going wrong
i think we did it i think we did i think
we did
oh my god
[Music]
it jiggles it's tall it's got brown top
quick cut
[Music]
oh it cuts nice
[Music]
i think compared to the video we got the
jiggle down
the light bottom but brown top down the
no crack
brand i didn't quite get quite right but
that's
yes adam come try this
[Music]